okay still a lot of people who want to
get on the phone at 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 let's go to let's go up to our
caller from the 5:09 area code caller
from 509 what's your name where you're
calling from yeah my name's David
I'm calling from Oh Richland Washington
alright what's going on um yeah I've
been kind of bugged by not you but
anyway by the all the media most of the
time I'm okay but I've really been or
irritated lately and I'm kind of curious
about your opinion the way they all
Trump manipulating them controlling the
narrative mm-hm
and what bothers me is the Mueller
report being turned over the bar and n
bar you know issuing the statement
there's nothing here he's all innocent
he's off you know and he's completely
free or whatever now my understanding
that the Department of Justice the
inspections were that Mueller was to do
a report and then turn it over the bar
bar would look for any legal
complications and say that was their
mistakes or did not meet the
requirements of law or that there was
things that were not legal done in it or
whatever and then he would turn it over
the Congress right and then Congress
would look at it the idea you know that
this whole process was not completed and
that's what kind of annoys me he you
know the media takes us you know go of
what the runs what the story that well
bar says there's nothing there
you know Trump is off or whatever and
that answers that question and the last
thing of course is a different really
the final judge here is really not
Congress it's going to be the American
people yeah well isn't listen I mean I
I've taught you you mentioned a few
things there I've talked about a number
of times now the media corporate media
dropped the ball on this bar
report this bar letter and a lot of the
reason why is because corporate media
just needs a simple and coherent
narrative so while the investigation was
going on the narrative was Trump's being
investigated now that we got this
political four-page letter
cherry-picking some stuff from the
Moller report it's too complicated to
say this is a letter but we don't have
the report but stuff has been turned
over to the Southern District of New
York and investigations continue and the
Moller grand jury has not been disbanded
and they're continuing and we might hear
it's just too complicated so they are
sort of influenced into running with a
simple and coherent narrative most of
them and it happens to be completely
inaccurate yeah yeah we certainly agree
there although I have to differ with you
I think it's tempest control the
narrative truck yeah I mean you're right
that also the Trump team has just sent
everybody out to say they've been
exonerated and even when a media outlets
don't accept that in a whole cloth it
still gets the message out there into
the into the echo chamber David all good
points and very well made I appreciate
it thank you
all right great to hear from you hope to
hear from you again